hey everybody producer Pat here bringing
you some holiday cheer on this Christmas
Eve let's get back into the news story
starting with this one about the 2024
presidential race a new poll finds that
a majority of Americans don't want to
see Donald Trump run for president again
but also a majority of Americans they
don't want to see Joe Biden run for
president again either the poll comes to
us from Echelon insights and the results
are that 55 percent of respondents don't
want to see Donald Trump seek the
presidency again in 2024 and that's
great news right but also statistically
just as many 54 percent of respondents
they say that they don't want to see Joe
Biden run again as well now on the
approval side when you flip the question
and ask do you want Trump to one run do
you want Biden to run there does seem to
be more support for Trump running than
Biden 39 give Trump the go-ahead whereas
only 34 say the same thing about Biden
so the question is three years out from
the next presidential race is this cause
for concern for Democrats I think part
of this is that that Americans are
saying they want to see new faces you
know if Trump runs again this will be
his third attempt he's been non-stop in
the political atmosphere ever since
2015. Biden he's been in the Senate
forever and then he was vice president
he ran a bunch of different presidential
campaigns and then of course now he is
the president so you know it's just time
to see some new people here we're sort
of sick of these guys and we don't want
to see an exact repeat of the 2020
election after all and part of this also
is the fact that they are quite up there
in age right if Trump gets elected in
2024 he's going to be 78 by the time
he's elected and 82 by the time he
leaves office and if Joe Biden gets
reelected he's going to be 82 at the
start of his second term and 86 by the
time that he's out of office and we know
that of course people now are living
longer lives these days and you can have
elderly people who are capable of doing
the job but some may say 80s that's kind
of pushing it maybe we need some younger
blood in there but I think this really
comes down to at the end of the day the
most important factor in in all of this
is that the hardcore Trump people who
make up somewhere between 35 to 40
unfortunately of the country they want
him no matter what right they don't care
about Ted Cruz they don't care about
Nikki Haley you know maybe Ron DeSantis
is okay but only as a backup option if
Trump doesn't want to run
um and so that's I think why we're
seeing the numbers show that 39 percent
of people say they do want Trump to run
those are the hardcore Trump supporters
whereas there's people who support Joe
Biden but they don't have the same sort
of cult of personality uh view of him
right Biden doesn't have this sort of
appeal that Trump does among his base of
supporters uh Biden's approval rating
right now is in the low to mid 40s which
is not great it's also not terrible but
the number who wants to see him run
again is uh again 34 which is
substantially lower than what his
approval number is at so that suggests
to me that there's a good amount of
people who are saying yeah I like what
Biden's doing but he's replaceable right
like if you give us common Harris if you
give us Pete booge or Elizabeth Warren
or whoever else will like them too
because at the end of the day it's more
about the cause than the person and then
also in addition you don't have to worry
about the age Factor you don't have to
worry about age or Fitness or anything
like that so that's my takeaway the
Trump people are wrapped up in the cult
of trump and the Biden people don't care
about Biden specifically they just want
to move the causes forward and I think
there's a real question whether Biden
will run again mainly because of the age
factor I think that if he chooses not to
run again obviously there will be a
primary in the Democratic field there's
a possibility that Kamala Harris being
the vice president she caught she gets
that coronation treatment that Hillary
Clinton got back in 2016. hopefully that
doesn't happen and hopefully we get some
Progressive challenges in there to make
it not so easy of a fight for her but
ultimately if Biden chooses to run again
he'll get the nomination and I think
Trump is definitely running again also I
mean he's dropping all these handsets to
how he's going to launch another
campaign I know some people like Michael
Cohen for example he's saying uh
including on the show he said I don't
think that Trump is going to run again
because he's terrified of losing for a
second time he doesn't want to be seen
as a two-time loser and the excuse of
voter fraud if he does lose isn't going
to work again but I just don't buy that
like first of all I think that if Trump
does run again he's going to have a
substantial chance at winning I think
he's actually going to get better odds
of winning than he did in 2016 or 2020
and if he does lose then he'll just tell
his voters yeah it was voter fraud and
they're already primed to believe the
voter fraud stuff they'll just say like
okay well they got us again those
Democrats rigging their elections so you
know I don't think Trump is really
worried about anything there it's sort
of a heads I win Tales you lose sort of
scenario where either he wins the
presidency or he just says once again
that he got cheated so the bottom line
is most Americans don't want to see
Trump run again most Americans don't
want to see Biden run again and yet
there's still a halfway decent shot that
we see yet another Trump Biden match up
a repeat heat of the last election cycle
in 2024 one of our sponsors is called
privacy privacy is a totally free
service that I've been using for years
privacy lets me create virtual payment
cards with one click and when I use the
virtual card the money is taken out of
my bank account you can create multiple
cards delete them freeze them set a
spending limit on them let's say I'm
signing up for a free trial and it
requires a credit card privacy will
autofill a virtual card number and then
after signing up I can delete that
virtual card so I know I'm not going to
be charged again something really useful
and very practical or let's say I'm
ordering food over the phone but I left
my wallet somewhere I don't have my real
credit card on me I can use a virtual
card on my privacy mobile app but really
the best part is you're not out there
exposing your real credit card number so
you're not a susceptible to to data
breaches and identity theft privacy is a
totally free service and you'll get five
bucks to spend when you go to
privacy.com Pacman the link is right
underneath this video